[Musique]
robert lepage ne change chez duceppe où
vous allez présenter au printemps 2023
votre projet riopel pour rendre hommage
à jean paul riopelle qui aurait eu 100
ans oui quelle idée avez vous en tête et
mon dieu plusieurs idées parce qu'on
peut pas de riopelle avec une seule idée
s'était lui même est un personnage
difficile à saisir
et époque un peintre un sculpteur
un coureur automobile veut dire celle
d'un homme qui a plusieurs facettes donc
c'est sûr que c'est un spectacle qui
aura plusieurs facettes 20e mais comment
on a décidé de parler de lui on ne scie
de faire un spectacle aussi qui serait
long alors ça fait partie des lots
spectacle fleuve de robert lepage avec
plusieurs un tract oui à 3 vous allez
onu difficile à trouver à l'excès c'est
donc ils recevaient une pause repas donc
comme les sept branches de la rivière
outaouais maillage de rousseau sur
poster comme le sabrage nommé
effectivement c'est ça votre spectacle
tant que je n'aurais pas autant qu'il y
en a dans le ciel
je peux pas m'arrêter de votre ville
natale québec vous pouvez voir au loin
les log rue c'est la fin de sa vie jean
paul riopelle d'amorcer métaphore il est
décédé en 2002 l'avez-vous déjà
rencontres n'ont jamais rencontré
pourtant j'ai l'impression de bien de
connaître parce que ça fait tellement
longtemps chez de la recherche sur lui
sur son aile bon évidemment j'ai eu le
bonheur de rencontrer sa fille j'ai
rencontré sa veuve puisqu'elle doit
changer je suis allé dans à peu près
toutes les maisons laquelle il a vécu
tous les ateliers où la paix donc
donc les besoins de l'avoir rencontré
mon dieu votre travail et à danser quand
même saisir ça fait quand même depuis
très longtemps que je m'intéresse à lui
mais j'avais pas l'occasion vraiment de
tentatives au début des années 2000
commencé à élaborer un spectacle sur
l'hudson sté complexité normes ponctuent
ce projet abandonné et mais j'ai
poursuivi cet intérêt largement je me
suis bien un jour un jour j'en joue
avec cette pandémie on va de vague en
vague et robert lepage est reconnue pour
toujours repoussé les limites des moyens
de tenir jusqu'à quel point ça vous
freine à votre élan sera justement
d'avoir des mesures sanitaires
brembo création ce qui a été difficile
surtout pour moi pour ma compagnie
peut-être moins pour le diamant c'est ne
pas pouvoir tourner nous nos sources de
financement sont principalement les
tournées donc pendant deux ans on fait
pas tourner et aussi nos sources
d'inspiration nos co produit avec des
brûlures l'étranger moi le voyage c'est
ma source d'inspiration première c'était
donc je parlais du maître et marguerite
magnifique roman de michael boulgakov
vous en effet une adaptation théâtrale à
moscou production arrêtée parce que vous
parlez leur de vous interprèteront
carrément fui la russie pour les
réfugiés vous avez dit récemment que les
russes vont éventuellement se soulever
contre la demi-heure poutine vous y
croyez encore oui mon jeune âge je
penche pour un prophète le musée se le
faire cette façon c'est la seule façon
que tout ça il faut quelqu'un brutus
faut qu'il faut qu'il y ait quelqu'un ou
quelqu'une qui se sacrifient ce qui
sacrifie évoqué quelqu'un qui fasse
quelque chose c'est de l'intérieur que
ça va se régler tout ça ils ont toujours
fait ça les russes historiquement ici
mais ça c'est le grand paradoxe des rues
c'est à dire que c'est des gens qui se
sont empressés notant toujours soit par
un tsar un tir en despote
un staline est en ce moment un poutine
et
sont écrasés de superman et révolution
et liberté mais la liberté c'est vrai
qu'une responsabilité et souvent des
ressources pour faire avec la liberté
les arts de la scène c'est toute votre
vie commencez vous de ce boycott des
artistes russes par exemple les scènes
qui a annulé la venue à la ksa dorment à
l'ofev et l conseil des arts du canada
ou aussi qui a annulé toutes ses
subventions aux artistes euros c'est ce
que moi je suis d'accord avec un boycott
n'est pas totale c'est à dire que
beaucoup de ces artistes chinois
acceptent dénoncé pour nous il faut leur
permettre de laisser ceux qui sont dans
une situation où il a cuit poutine ou
encore qui sont dans une situation
précaire vous appuyez patine mais pour
parler contre lui parce qu'ils ont des
familles en russie puis ils veulent pas
que leur présent et tout ça alors vous
pourrez faut bien qu'on peut pour
analyser je pense qu'on peut dire on
bricole il ne faut pas faire ça je pense
vous regarder chaque cas
[Musique]
j'ai vu un septembre 2010 note la
reprise de votre production et des sept
branches de la rivière atoll demain
j'adorais ce spectacle qui pourrait
revivre à québec à montréal
éventuellement ou des journaux des plans
pour éventuellement revenir à morlaàs
venir à québec c'est dans les cartons
mais je pars
ce soir pour berlin où on va jouer les
scènes quand j'avais un retour à l'achat
ou d'une janis fait cela robert lepage
puis on y présente les seuls dangers
reliés retail la semaine suivante
représente 8,7 et vous êtes modeste on
va vous remettre prie aussi pour
monsieur jeu peut se poser savoir mais
bon ok oui on
file station merci beaucoup merci bon
voyage merci
[Musique]